CHRISTIAN DUBÉ
ministre de la Santé, Québec
- Ça va être un hiver
excessivement difficile, parce
qu'on lutte contre trois virus.
- Les nouvelles du ministre
québécois de la Santé sont peu
réjouissantes.
(pleurs bébé)
Les urgences pédtrtriques
débordent et pas de répit en
vue. À l'Hôpital Sainte-Justine,
300 enfants sont admis par jour,
le double de la capacité
d'accueil.
- Mon fils, il fait une
pneumonie, et puis c'est un peu
sévère, là. Ça fait depuis hier
qu'on attend d'avoir une
chambre.
- "Mais où est donc la santé
publique pour conseiller
la population en matière
de prévention?", demande
une médededede Sainte-Justine.
Sa collègue est d'accord,
le message des autorités doit
être plus clair.
FATIAKAKAKKAR, infectiologue
pédiat., Hôpital Sainte-Justine
- Ce qui m'inquiète, c'est que
les gens ne s'isolent plus quand
ils sont malades, en général.
Donc, j'ai beaucoup de gens qui
se promènent avec mal de gorge,
le nez qui coule, des rhumes,
sans porter le masque.
- Vous avez des symptômes,
vous portez un masque.
- Pour l'instant, la santé
publique demande aux Québécois
d'user de leur bon sens.
Le Dr Luc Boileau recommande
le masque dans les lieux publics
pour les plus à risque ou
pour ceux qui ont les symptômes
d'un virus respiratoire.
En Ontario, des chirurgies
pour enfants sont repoussées,
de nouveaux lits en soins
intensifs sont ouverts.
Des discussions sur
la réintroduction du masque
dans les lieux publics ont cours
et le médecin hygiéniste en chef
fera une annonce lundi matin.
Pour sa part, le gouvernement
fédéral insiste sur la
vaccination contre la COVID-19
et la grippe.
JEAN-YVES DUCLOS
ministre fédéral de la Santé
- C'est qu'il faut faire
de prudence si on veut aider
nos travailleurs de la santé
à prendre soin des gens qui
en ont le plus besoin.
Il faut individuelle
selon ces experts, faire
attention. Se faire vacciner,
c'est la base.
- Mais contrairement aux deux
dernières  l'approche
des Fêtes, les gouvernements
semblent tout de même peu
enclins à réintroduire des
restrictions.
Ici C D D D D Dumouli